hi there here we are in uh
in san diego the outskirts of san diego
a special milestone birthday for my wife
come down here for a nice golf holiday
because in this area it's supposed to be
sunny all the time
uh
we got in golf yesterday although it was
a little bit sort of windy but today it
rained all day and it's supposed to rain
tomorrow so we're kind of stuck
uh rain we have in vancouver
but we have to try to make the best of
it
so my wife brought down some sewing
which she's doing
and uh
we we
visited around a bit and um
now and then i got in my career it's
easier to study at home because there
are so many things that i do like when i
drive to the office to play hockey go
skiing drive anywhere
i'm in the car i can listen
i do the dishes every night there's
another 15 20 minutes other tasks around
the house
i can easily get in an hour or even an
hour and a half of listening which is my
major language learning activity
here my wife and i are together most of
the time i can't be walking around with
earphones plugged into my ear
but i sat down and uh at link today
probably spent a good two hours two and
a half hours i went into my uh my
lessons area at link and saw that i had
some courses there one was on history
that i had imported from before
or i got it from the library i don't
know where i started working on it
it's good in some ways it's very
interesting because i have the
naver dictionary both
from
korean or hangul into english and from
hangul
into hanja into chinese characters
because it's very helpful to me
come and you can't whistle while i'm on
my video
my wife is sewing while she listens to
her piano lessons
but she's got her because i'm doing the
video she's got her earphones
plugged in and she started whistling
so at home she plays the piano to
accompany my videos
um where was that yeah so i look up the
hanja which is very helpful help helps
me remember and and and it just gives me
the hunger for some of these korean
kings from the bek jay period or the you
know silla period or whatever it might
be
uh but it's just too difficult so i
stopped doing that i spent maybe half an
hour there then i found another uh
collection i went actually to the chosen
elbow and there was an article quite a
long one
about korean who had married an american
woman and i i don't know what it all is
about because i've gone through
saving the words that i need
and so it's going to be you know a word
or two every second third line so i get
a very rough idea of what the story is
about and now i'm going to go back in
and read it perhaps save some additional
words and phrases tag them if necessary
and so forth so there's i spent a good
two two and a half hours
what i'm reminded of when i do this is
just how much work is involved in
learning a language
first of all
korean is is takes longer than say
italian or other
languages that i've done
because first of all the google
translate translation is extremely bad
there are very that is to say unreliable
in most cases
there are not so many user hints so i'm
having you with a dictionary all the
time and often i look up the dictionary
twice because i'll normally go to the
english one and if i suspect that there
is a chinese character a hundja lurking
there then i'll go to the hanja to get
the hanja dictionary so it's just taking
a lot of time but in any language there
are a lot of words
unless you have sort of a freebie
vocabulary because it's a related
language you're learning portuguese and
you know spanish or you're learning
romanian and you know italian
so there's a lot of words to learn it
takes long a long time
a lot of listening and reading
so it's important for this to be
enjoyable and i find it enjoyable
because i choose things that are of
interest to me
and uh but it takes a long time which
reminds me there was a person um i think
on my youtube channel who was studying
italian and thanked me for reminding her
that it's important to enjoy
our learning activities and because she
had been studying lists of words and
learning in italian learning italian in
a way that's not particularly enjoyable
it's a long road you may as well enjoy
it
i had a question on link from someone
who said i'm going to germany in three
months i want to study during the summer
what can i do and what can i achieve
of course i recommend it just do it the
way we do it at link listen and read if
you want you can get a little grammar
book to leave through but we have so
many good
lessons including lessons on grammar for
german that link you'll be fully
occupied but find the time to listen and
try and do more than an hour a day
and
how much will you achieve in three
months i don't know
i don't think we should put these kinds
of pressures on ourselves whatever you
do
in three months will make your visit to
germany that one more that much more
enjoyable so just do things that you
find interesting and enjoyable and
expect to see your level improve that's
it uh similarly with me now i don't know
what i'm going to achieve
here in my three months with
korean it's a it's a big task but i know
that my korean is better than it was at
the beginning and it'll be better when
i'm done
and if i have the opportunity to go to
korea thereafter i will do much much
better there than
if i had not gone through this period so
that the benefits are there
you do improve
but there are no guarantees as to what
you will how much you can improve in how
short a period of time
in terms of improving my
flu is certainly a lot better and i hope
too that the weather is better tomorrow
and that's it for today day 45